Und du wirst deswegen am 11. September auf der Demo mit dabei sein. Was ist dein Lieblings-Demospruch?
Ich finde eigentlich, dass in diesem Jahr Freiheit statt Angst gerade auch gegen das sprechende Datum sehr gut passt. Ich weiß noch nicht genau, was es dieses Jahr sein wird. Letztes Jahr hatte ich keinen lauten Spruch, sondern bin ich selbst mit einer großen, gebauten Tab-Kamera und als Pippi Langstrumpf verkleidet auf der Demo gewesen. Weil ich dachte so, als das freieste Mädchen der Welt auf einer Demo zu sein, ist eigentlich eine ganz coole Sache. Allerdings haben das ziemlich viele Leute auch nicht verstanden und haben gedacht, oh, jetzt artet das Ganze in einem Love Parade aus. Aber okay, das war dann halt so. Da bin ich dieses Jahr noch am Überlegen. Wichtig da jetzt im Moment, als mir Demosprüche für den 11. September auszudenken, ist mir eigentlich Leute aktiv darauf hinzuweisen, dass diese Veranstaltung stattfindet und die, die es wissen, auch darauf hinzuweisen, dass man sich zum Beispiel im Aktionsbüro in der Hessischen Straße oder auch in der Pflugstraße im Büro der Piratenpartei Flyer abholen kann, Plakate, die man an seiner Lieblingskneipe aufhängen kann, abholen kann, dass man bei E-Mails, die man verschickt, einfach an den Fuß einen kleinen Reminder schicken kann, hey Leute, hängen kann, hey Leute, denkt dran, da ist die Demo, kommt hin. Also einfach dafür zu sorgen, dass überhaupt genug Leute mitbekommen, da wird diese Veranstaltung sein. Und ehrlich gesagt ist das auch mit einer der Gründe, weshalb ich mich heute angerufen habe, weil ich halt die, die jetzt zuhören motivieren möchte, selbst wenn sie nicht hingehen, zu gucken, wie kann ich es schaffen, dass mindestens ein, zwei Leute in meinem Umfeld davon erfahren und das auch wieder weitersagen.
Selbst wenn man selber nichts zur Demo gibt, sollte man sich wenigstens mit dem Thema beschäftigt haben, um dann eine bewusste Entscheidung zu treffen, ob man dahin geht oder nicht.
Das ist das eine. Ich glaube aber auch, dass wenn Leute sagen, ja sie können an dem Tag nicht kommen, weil dieses oder das ist, dann sollen sie halt jemanden schicken, der sie da vertritt und verwürdig.
Okay, vielleicht ist das auch eine neue Marktlücke, Demo-Vertreter.
Da gab es übrigens auch schon lustige Schilder auf den letzten zwei Demos zu genau diesem Thema. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau die Sprüche, aber so in der Art gab es schon Geschichten. Mir aber ernsthaft, also mir ist wirklich wichtig, dass die Leute wissen, hey wir können jetzt noch aktiv was dazu tun, dass einfach diese Themen wahrgenommen werden. Wir können nämlich über die Themen schreiben, reden, Mails verschicken, Leute anrufen, was auch immer und dabei auch zum Beispiel diese Veranstaltung.
Wie du es jetzt gerade reichhaltig getan hast, ich muss jetzt direkt mal Andreas und Nibbler vom Chaos Computer Club fragen, wollt ihr jetzt noch was anfügen oder machen wir die restlichen 50 Minuten Musik?
Ich glaube man kann zu dem Thema noch ganz viel sagen, also redet ruhig weiter.
Alles klar, danke Manuela, hat es erlaubt. Dann dir vielen Dank und viel Spaß beim Demonstrieren.
Alles klar, bis dann.
So, man, das war ja schon mal ein sehr ausführliches Plädoyer, dafür zur Demo zu gehen und sich im Zeitungsfall vertreten zu lassen.
Das finde ich gut.
Wir haben ja aber hier immer noch die große Liste mit den ganz vielen Themen. Da steht ja auch der e-Paar drauf. Heißt der nicht mittlerweile anders?
Der heißt e-Paar, genau, e-Paar, neuer Personalausweis.
Können wir noch kurz zusammenfassen, was da drin ist, worum es da geht und warum wir den auf der Demo auch erwähnen?
Verschiedene Punkte, die da drin sind. Zum einen ein RFID-Chip, also ein drahtlos auslesbares Stückchen Elektronik wird Bestandteil des neuen Personalausweises sein. Dann biometrische Daten, also nachdem die Reisepässe jetzt schon biometrisch geworden sind, geht die biometrische Vollerfassung der Bevölkerung in die finale Phase. Jetzt kriegt jeder seine biometrische Erfassung. Das sind natürlich auch Probleme. Also in den 70er Jahren, als die ersten Vorschläge kamen, man könne ja eine Datenbank mit biometrischen Merkmalen anlegen, weil da gab es ja diese RF, das hat noch unglaubliche Proteststürme ausgelöst. Damals war das komplett unvorstellbar, dass irgendwie die komplette Bevölkerung erkennungsdienstlich behandelt wird. Und mit dem neuen Personalausweis wird das jetzt halt Realität.
Woher kommt das eigentlich? Was glaubst du, woran liegt das, dass dieser Protest so nachgelassen hat? Ist es den Leuten einfach egal oder haben sie erkannt, das ist gar nicht so schlimm?
Das ist eine spannende Frage. Vermutlich haben die meisten irgendwann aufgegeben, also zu sagen, nach 5 Jahren oder 10 Jahren oder 20 Jahren dagegen ist dann sowas wie, na gut, wenn es sein muss. Das denke ich steckt dahinter.
Wurde einem ja auch schmackhaft gemacht. Heißt ja nicht, dass man da für seinen Ausweis eine erkennungsdienstliche Behandlung, sondern legen sie mal den Finger hier auf den Sense und dann können sie mit ihrem Ausweis ganz viele tolle neue Dinge tun. So ist schon ein Unterschied, wie man das ganze labelt. Und da sind in letzter Zeit schon sehr häufig sehr vorsichtig umschrieben worden, was man meint. Und eben nicht gesagt, hier geht es um einmal Vollerfassung aller biometrischen Daten, sondern halt um angenehme Träume.
Gibt es auch ein paar Vorteile, man kann es dann online identifizieren.
Genau.
Das ist ja auch alles ganz ungefährlich, wie wir diese Woche gelernt haben. Und der Rüdiger hat angerufen, weil er auch was zum E-Pass sagen will.
Rüdiger, tach.
Ja, genau, ich habe letztes Mal mit ein paar Leuten darüber gesprochen, weil ich in einer gewissen Partei tätig bin. Und es ist ja zum Beispiel auch so, dass viele Länder gar keinen Personalausweis haben, da gibt es halt nur einen Reisepass. Es ist ja schon seltsam, dass wir natürlich beides brauchen in der BRD, dass wir dann auch diese ganzen überflüssigen Daten damit reinmachen sollen, obwohl die Technik ja noch nicht mal ausgereift ist, nur weil da irgendjemand sich profilieren möchte, so ähnlich wie die Riester-Rente, und da sein Name irgendwo steht, damit er sich so ein Ding mal setzt oder so. Genau, solche biometrischen Daten und sowas, ich weiß nicht, was das bringen soll. Das gibt es ja nicht möglich sein, außer dass man jetzt vielleicht dann meine Augeniris hat oder sowas in einer Art, und jederzeit mal kurz gucken kann, wer ich bin, oder dass ich meinen Ausweis zeige. Das kann ja nicht im Sinne des Erfinders, also doch bestimmt im Sinne des Erfinders, aber das hat ja nichts mit dem Schutz der Bevölkerung oder sonst irgendwas zu tun.
Würdest du denn deswegen zur Demo gehen?
Nicht nur.
Nicht nur, weswegen denn noch?
Generell halt, weil wenn man sich mal so ein bisschen damit beschäftigt, dann lernt man ja doch die Sachen kennen, dass das ein sehr, sehr langer Rattenschwanz ist und dass der Staat ja wirklich nicht nur so ein Projekt hat, wo er gerne mal ein bisschen mehr über uns wissen möchte, sondern ganz viele andere Sachen auch. Also Elena zum Beispiel, oder dieses Acta und dieses ganze Zeug, was total intransparent ist. Und das ist auf jeden Fall eine gute Sache. Das war doch dieser Zusammenschluss, wo sich Nationen sich ganz transparenten Vertrag ausdenken, wie man gegen Urheberrechtsverletzungen zu, wie man dagegen angehen kann. Das macht man natürlich alles geheim. Da darf auch nichts an die Öffentlichkeit geraten. Warum, weiß ich nicht. Aber irgendwie sind da ganz viele Nationen daran beteiligt. Und die wollen da halt wohl so einen internationalen Vertrag ausarbeiten, damit man diese schwerste aller Verbrechen besser behandeln kann.
Können wir gleich noch nicht mal versuchen, genauer zu beantworten. Rüdiger, wie wirst du zur Demo gehen? Also wie wird das bei dir aussehen?
Ich hab mich schon verabredet. Ich werde mit ein paar Leuten von einer Piratenpartei hingehen.
Jaja, aber wirst du dann sozusagen in Jeans und Parteiuniform? Oder ist dein Kurs transparent?
Ja, gehen wir schon ein Fähnchen und ein T-Shirt gleich anziehen. Also man weiß, wo ich hingehöre. Aber an sich hab ich mir gedacht, zu Elena könnte man eigentlich ein ziemlich gutes Wahlplakat machen. Man könnte sie ja zum Beispiel als eine Auskunftswillige Schlampe darstellen.
Wie genau soll das aussehen?
Vielleicht, wie sie gerade einem Politiker oral befriedigt oder sowas. Und er dann irgendwie sagt, ja bitte gib mir deine Daten oder so eine Art Sprechblase so darüber.
Als ich vorhin nach Elena gegoogelt habe, sind mir auch jede Menge leichtbekleidete Mädels positiv geworden.
Ja, das sieht mir auch richtig nach, oder? Alles mit Elster.
Mit was?
Mit Elster.
Was ist das?
Die elektronische Steuererklärung.
Aber mit Elstern will ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Okay, wir schweifen gerade ab. Rüdiger, dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank und viel Spaß beim Plakatmalen. Das wird sicherlich lustig. Wir erwarten dann Fotos. So, so, dann wisst ihr also Bescheid. Um nochmal zurück zu Akta zu kommen, was genau, könntest du mal genauer erklären, was da passieren soll und warum man dagegen sein könnte oder vielleicht doch.
Akta ist, ich musste bloß gerade nochmal nachgucken wegen dem Herrn Schilli und seiner Involviertheit in die Bundesdruckerei. Und also ging es nicht um den Namen, da ging es um Geld. Da hat jemand viel Geld verdient mit der Bundesdruckerei GmbH, die mittlerweile wieder in Staatsbesitz ist. Akta ist natürlich ein Thema, da geht es erstmal um Urheberrecht. Das klingt erstmal so, als hätte es gar nichts mit Datenschutz zu tun, hat es aber wohl doch. Und zwar ist es so, dass die Urheberrechtsindustrie, die Musikindustrie, die Filmindustrie, die Verleger und ähnliche Konsorten ihre Freunde bedroht sehen im Internet und gerne die Knappheit physikalischer Güter, auch auf die Knappheit von eigentlich relativ leicht zu kopierenden Bits übertragen wollen. Und zu diesem Zwecke also ein sehr rigides Regime durchsetzen möchten, das verhindert, dass man rechte behaftete Bitmuster durch das Internet schiebt. Und die Mittel, die sie sich dazu vorstellen, sind also sehr weitreichend. Das läuft also darauf hinaus, dass die zum Beispiel einen Auskunftsanspruch haben wollen. Das heißt, ich als Rechteinhaber kann irgendwo hingehen und sagen, du hast da alles meins, sag mir mal wer das dahin getan hat. Und dann soll der Provider verpflichtet sein, die persönlichen Daten des Betreffenden rauszugeben. Also völlig vorbei an normalen Verfahren. Und auch für die Schwere des Verbrechens total unangemessen.
Das ist ungefähr so wie der Typ da drüben, das könnte ein Handtaschenräuber sein. Ich guck da mal eben in die Wohnung rein, ob meine Handtasche, die mir geraubt wurde, dort liegt.
Also Akda hat da noch mehr Aspekte. Da gibt es auch diese Geschichte, dass die den Leuten das Internet abklemmen wollen, wenn sie sich mehrfach haben mit urheberrechtsbehafteten Material erwischen lassen. Man kennt das aus Frankreich. Das ist dann vielleicht für das Thema Datenschutz und Freiheit statt Angst nicht mehr so relevant. Aber die Leute, die mit urheberrechtlich geschütztem Material Geld verdienen, die sind halt offensichtlich sehr einflussreich und schaffen es, internationale Verträge anzuleiern, die hinter verschlossenen Türen verhandelt werden, wo es im Endeffekt auch um unsere Daten, unsere Freiheit, sich im Internet zu bewegen geht.
Was hat es denn da mit den verschossenen Türen eigentlich an sich, weil du hast jetzt gerade viel davon erzählt, worum es geht. Was genau hat das mit der Geheimhaltung, die Rüdiger auch gerade schon erwähnt hat?
Die hat halt irgendwie streckenweise nicht ganz so gut funktioniert. Gelegentlich bekommt man halt mal Dokumente zugespielt aus diesem Prozess, was nichts daran ändert, dass man das meiste nicht weiß, dass die Verhandlungen hinter geschlossenen Türen laufen. Letzten Endes ist das so ein Ding, eigentlich wollten die fertig sein, bevor die Weltöffentlichkeit überhaupt irgendwas erfährt.
Das hat anscheinend nicht ganz so geklappt, ist aber auch gut, dann wissen wir übrigens, worüber wir dagegen, nee, wogegen wir da demonstrieren können. Das ist wieder so ein Thema, wo ich auch mal fragen würde, da wird immer gesagt, was ihr wollt, das wollen wir nicht so, dagegen, dagegen. Gibt es zu dieser ganzen Urheberrechtsdebatte da eine positive Lösung, die man auch mitnehmen könnte und aufs Plakat schreiben, so, hier, so machen wir das in Zukunft?
Also ich hab da mittlerweile eine sehr pragmatische Einstellung dazu. Und es gibt zwei Sorten von Leuten, die einen wollen, gehört, gelesen und gesehen werden und die wollen, dass ihr Content auch noch in 100 oder 200 Jahren verfügbar ist. Und dann gibt es Leute, die nehmen kurzfristig die Chance, vielleicht ein bisschen Geld zu verdienen, weil für die meisten Künstler ist es ja so eine Art Lottospiel. Man hat die 0, 1% Chance, die Millionen zu verdienen, die anderen darben eher. Dagegentauscht, dass man in 20 Jahren halt nicht mehr gehört wird, weil die Musik sicher nicht kopieren ließ und der Verlag, der die Keys für das DRM hat, der ist mittlerweile pleite. Also wer halt der Meinung ist, er möchte einen Althergebrachten Urheberrechtsmuster publizieren, der soll das tun und der ist dem Untergang geweiht.
Na ja gut, aber bis der Untergang stattfindet, ist es ja doch so, dass da irgendwie raufkopiert wird. Aber das gibt sozusagen ein Problem, wo es keine Lösung zu gibt.
Das ist ein... Na ja, das muss man wahrscheinlich gesamtgesellschaftlich lösen. Da sind wir jetzt wieder bei der Grundsicherung, weil wenn es Grundsicherung für alle gibt, dann gibt es auch Grundsicherung für Künstler. Und dann kann jeder, der der Meinung ist, er möchte Musik machen, sich mit seiner Gitarre in die Ecke setzen, Musik machen und irgendwie, wenn er schlecht ist, kriegt er halt weiter Grundsicherung, wie alle anderen auch, die nichts machen. Und wenn er ein bisschen besser ist, kriegt er vielleicht, wenn er in der Kneipe spielt, mal ein Bier spendiert. Bis hin zu wie viel hat YouTube jetzt verdient? Ich glaube 60 Millionen pro Nase auf ihrer Konzerttournee. Die haben überhaupt gar kein Problem damit, dass Leute ihre Musik kopieren, weil sie immer noch einen echten Arsch voller Kohle damit verdienen, dass sie einfach auf der Bühne stehen. Und da sehe ich halt auch eine Lösung. Das Tonträger kopieren war halt früher mal ein Geschäft, weil man mit physikalischen Datenträgern verbunden ist jetzt nicht mehr so. Dann muss man halt anders versuchen, die Künstler zu kompensieren. Und eine Kronensicherung wird helfen. Das betrifft dann auch Softwareautoren, das betrifft dann auch Journalisten, Blogger und so weiter und so fort.
Aber darum wird es bei der DEMO nicht gehen.
Das ist nicht der Fall. Das war jetzt nur ein Rand an der Seite. Ich sag doch, das ist größtenteils themenfremd.
Verstehe, verstehe. Es taucht auch, ich glaube auch in dem CCC-Aufruf, das Wort Post-Privacy-Spacken, glaube ich. Das ist kein wörtliches Zitat, aber so ungefähr in der Richtung wird da was gesagt. Was ist dieses komische Post-Privacy und warum würde es auf der DEMO unter Umständen eine Rolle spielen?
Post-Privacy ist die Philosophie und Überlegung, dass das mit dem Datenschutz eh alles hoffnungslos und zu spät vorbei ist und eh demnächst jeder alles über jeden weiß und so nach dem Motto Deal with it. Man muss damit klarkommen. Und ist natürlich...
Um es mal kurz zum Gehör zu bringen, ich hab's noch jetzt gefunden, auch alle, denen das Privacy is dead Gelaber aus der Industrie schon aus den Ohren kommt, dürfen mit kreativen Plakaten richtig beherzt dagegen protestieren. Privacy is dead Gelaber ist ja dann sozusagen dieses Post Privacy.
Ja, Mark Zuckerberg ist da glaube ich einer der größten Proponenten. Es ist kein Wunder, der verdient auch viel Geld mit den Daten seiner User. Aber auf der anderen Seite gibt es auch Leute, die sagen, es ist vorbei, es ist sinnlos. Und es gibt ja auch Kulturen, in denen das anders funktioniert als in Deutschland. Also es gibt ja einen sehr spezifischen Grund, warum gerade in Deutschland der Datenschutz zu hoch gehalten wird. Und das ist der, dass die Judenvernichtung im dritten Reich logistisch nur deswegen möglich war, weil auf Holorid-Lochkarten-Maschinen-Klammer-auf-später-IBM-Klammer-zu die Bevölkerung komplett erfasst und gezählt wurde. Und nach statistischen Merkmalen sortierbar war, die Kontenhaltenden zu dem Stapel Lochkarten greifen. Und suchen wir mal alle Juden raus, in folgendem Postleitzahlenbereich einstellen. Und dann konnten sie den Tropos schicken, der die abholt. Und diese Erinnerung ist eigentlich der Grund, warum gerade in Deutschland das mit dem Datenschutz so wichtig ist. Es gibt Kulturen, das ist ein bisschen anders. Wenn man in die skandinavischen Länder geht, da ist es völlig normal, dass man weiß, wie viel der Nachbar verdient, weil man kann ja so eine Steuererklärung auf der Website des Finanzamtes abrufen. Die haben da einen anderen Umgang mit.
Aber wäre das nicht auch bei uns in der Zeit, sagen da mal, so ein bisschen vorwärts geworden, das Ganze zu untersuchen?
Ich glaube, da ist auch die Gesellschaft noch nicht so weit. Weil was würde das in der Praxis bedeuten? Es gibt auch in Deutschland Entwicklungen, die dahingehen, dass man bestimmte Sachen nicht mehr verheimlichen muss. Vor 30 Jahren hatten wir doch einen großen Skandal, weil ein General der Bundeswehr seinen Job verloren hat, weil er schwul ist. Weil wenn er schwul ist, ist er ja durch ausländische Mächte erpressbar. Und sowas ist heutzutage komplett unvorstellbar. Das ist einfach vorbei. Damit, dass jemand schwul ist, ist das keine große Neuigkeit mehr. Er kommt wirklich irgendwo vom Dorf. Ähnlich war es mal eine Zeit lang anrüchig, wenn man bloß sich hat scheiden und wieder verheiraten lassen. Heutzutage steht in der Klatschspalte, Fußballer X oder Schauspieler Y hat neben seiner Freundin und seiner Geliebten noch eine Nebenfreundin. Und das interessiert auch keine Sau mehr. Aber das geht halt natürlich dann weiter. Ich versuche immer mal gerne als Gedankenexperiment mir vorzustellen, wenn ich in diesen Bundestag reingucke und sage, ich möchte jetzt Gesetz X oder Y durchsetzen, warum auch immer. Es ist ja nicht so schwer da die Keyplayer zu finden. Meine Theorie ist, dass wenn man sich anguckt, wie viele davon, keine Ahnung, Drogen konsumieren oder Prostituierte besuchen oder dann doch heimlich schwul sind oder eine Geliebte haben oder irgendwie, was sonst alles anrüchig ist, was Leute tun, was verboten ist, Steuern hinterziehen, wobei das so ziemlich der einzige Punkt ist, den ich moralisch nicht vertreten kann, dann kommt man so auf eine Mehrheit. Wir leben einfach in einer Gesellschaft, die auch ein Stück weit auf die Lüge aufgebaut ist, also auf die gegenseitige Übereinkunft, dass es halt bestimmte Dinge gibt, die gibt es halt nicht, über die redet man nicht, die macht aber trotzdem jeder. Wenn wir erst mal so weit sind, dass man da problemlos drüber reden kann und keine Repressalen zu befürchten hat, dann funktioniert vielleicht auch so eine Post-Privacy-Gesellschaft, aber vorher einfach nicht.
Man muss sich einfach mal vorstellen, man geht jetzt zum Bäcker und in dem Moment, wo man diesen Laden betritt, weiß man alles, was dieser Bäcker so in seiner Freizeit tut. Also 90% unseres Alltags beruht darauf, dass wir eben genau nicht wissen, was das gegenüber in seiner Komplexität an Persönlichkeit tut und ist und vertritt und so weiter, sondern beruht darauf, dass man sich in funktionaler Weise ergänzt, dass man jemanden wirklich in seiner Funktion sieht. Ich gehe jetzt zum Finanzamt und habe dann einen Finanzbeamten, mit dem ich irgendwie über Steuern rede. Und da interessiert einen das einfach auch gar nicht.
Aber vielleicht würde uns das unsere Gesellschaft viel menschlicher machen. Wenn wir alle von allem was wissen, man könnte sich immer mit Menschen unterhalten und nicht nur mit Funktionen, wäre das nicht großartig?
Das ist sicherlich in manchen Teilen eine attraktive Vision. Ich glaube, dass die Befürchtung, die viele Leute haben, ist, dass da einfach keine Symmetrie gibt, sondern dass da eine Macht-Asymmetrie entsteht. Dass es halt die wenigen gibt, die alles über alle wissen und die große ungewaschene Masse, die halt nichts über alles weiß. Aber vielleicht ist dem auch nicht so.
Das könnten wir vielleicht gleich noch mal ein bisschen vertiefen. Vorher machen wir aber Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr und danach geht's gleich noch eine halbe Stunde weiter mit dem Chaos Radio. Halbe Stunde haben wir noch hier im Chaosradio am letzten Mittwoch im Monat, wo es heute um die Demo Freiheit statt Angst geht, die am 11. September stattfinden soll. Andreas und Nibbler vom Chaos Computer Club sind hier, um zu sagen, dass es doch eine gute Idee ist, dass man da hingehen kann. Oder habe ich das jetzt falsch verstanden die letzten anderthalb Stunden?
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Nochmal ganz kurz, warum?
Wegen der guten Party. Ne, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Unter vielen Leuten und überhaupt und...
Nochmal ganz kurze Zusammenfassung.
Es gibt ja da politische Dinge, die passieren sollen. Welche sind das?
Ne, die eben nicht passieren sollen. Oder anders passieren sollen.
Die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist das wichtigste Beispiel. Und dann gibt es aber noch eine lange Liste von anderen Themen, die wir da haben. Wir haben Elena, die Arbeitnehmer-Daten-Erfassung. Wir haben das Akta-Abkommen, wo es darum geht, dass bei Urheberrechtsverletzungen die Daten der Internet-User rausgeben werden sollen. Wir haben den elektronischen Personalausweis. Klammerauf, holt euch noch schnell ein. Ihr habt noch zwei Monate Zeit, der danach wird auch teurer. Und ihr müsst so böse gucken auf den Bildklammer.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wie lange habe ich Zeit meinen zu verlieren?
Bis Ende Oktober musst du den verloren haben. Gut. Wir haben die Volkszählung, die ansteht, also der Zensus.
Das hatten wir heute noch gar nicht. Da würde ich doch gleich mal gerne noch ein bisschen drauf rumhacken. Das verstehe ich nämlich immer noch nicht so richtig. Volkszählung, man zählt ja wie viele Leute da sind, das ist doch super.
Ja, und man erfasst alle ihre statistischen Merkmale und kennt dann jeden Einzelnen. Wie genau alle? Was geplant ist, da das mit der Volkszählung ja so einen schlechten Ruf hat, aus schon erläuterten Gründen, will man das nicht so machen, deswegen hat man sich jetzt auf das kleine Modell geeinigt. Das heißt, was passiert ist ein Registerdatenabgleich. Das heißt, die vielen Datenbanken, die vielen kleinen Datenbanken, die überall existieren, beim lokalen Einwohnermeldeamt, muss man ja sagen, das gibt es bislang noch nicht, das zentrale Register, wo alle Deutschen gespeichert sind, sondern man wird von seinem lokalen Einwohnermeldeamt verwaltet. Diese Daten sollen alle zusammengekippt werden mit den gesetzlichen Versicherungsdaten und was es da sonst noch alles gibt und einmal quer durchgerührt, um auch wirklich jeden zu erwischen und zu gucken, ob die Daten überall konsistent sind. Und zusätzlich dazu sollen Stichproben, auch wieder ein Anführungszeichen, befragt werden. Das sind, ich glaube, 10% der Bevölkerung, die dann einen Fragewogen bekommen, den sie gefälligst wahrheitsgemäß auszufüllen haben, wo auch wieder dann Stichproben gemacht werden, ob sie denn wahrheitsgemäß ausgefüllt wurden mit entsprechenden Strafen, falls man es nicht wahrheitsgemäß ausfüllt.
Wie, wenn man bei einer Volksdefinition nicht mitmacht, wird man bestraft?
Jaja, das verboten dann nicht mitzumachen. Na, irgendwie ist halt nur eine Ordnungswidrigkeit und kostet dich halt ein bisschen Geld. Also wenn du viel Geld hast, dann ist das nicht so ein Problem. Aber das ist tatsächlich eine Ordnungswidrigkeit, diesen Fragebogen dann nicht auszufüllen.
Okay, das ist auch ein Thema, das auf der Demo vorkommen konnte. Tatsächlich hab ich gerade gesehen, in die Telefonanlage spinnt dann gerade ein bisschen. Hat gerade einen Carsten, glaub ich, angerufen, der uns sagen wollte, dass wir am Thema vorbei reden. Das ist natürlich die Gefahr, so ein bisschen, glaube ich, die entstehen kann, weil es umso viel geht mittlerweile bei der Demo. Oder gibt es ein, kann ich sagen, ein großes Thema? Also weil es scheint schon so, man fängt jetzt an zu sagen, ok, Datenschutz hängt irgendwie mit drin, aber es gibt da das und das und das und das und überhaupt, dann müssen wir mal gucken, dann müssen wir eine Kamera mitnehmen. Kann das nicht die Leute irgendwann dann auch überfordern? Also ist dann auch nicht die Gefahr, dass diese Demo genau zu so einem diffusen Happening verkommt, wo man hingeht, weil es ist halt irgendwie für eine gute Sache, aber eigentlich weiß keiner mehr so richtig genau, worum es geht?
Nachdem wir die Love Parade jetzt nicht mehr haben, ja?
Du böser, böser Mann. Boge, ich bin erschüttert. Nein, aber mal ehrlich.
Der Punkt ist halt auch, andere Aspekte der gleichen Thematik kennenzulernen auf dieser Demo. Vielleicht trägt man sich über das eine oder andere Gesetz auf, stellt dann aber fest, da gibt es ja noch das und das, was auch gerade überhaupt nicht gut läuft. Ich sehe das durchaus als Horizont erweitern und nicht als zerfasern.
Das widerspricht ja auch ein bisschen dem dezentralen Ansatz, den wir alle pflegen. Zu sagen, hier ist jetzt die Demo und das sind die von oben verordneten Demothemen für dieses Jahr. Wir haben dieses Jahr das Demomod und ihr müsst alle mitmachen. Sondern auch zu sagen, es ist hier ein Raum für Leute, die sich zu einem bestimmten Thema äußern können, was vielleicht auch die anderen, die das Thema Datenschutz, die das Thema persönliche Freiheit wichtig finden, mal wahrnehmen müssen, um das in die Debatte zu bringen.
Ich meine, das ist gar nicht so in Hinsicht zu sagen, dass jetzt ein Thema verordnet wird. Aber bei den ersten Demos gab es das große Thema Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Da war ganz klar, wo es hingeht. Und jetzt ist es so, okay, wir machen diese Demo, weil sie hat Tradition und wir machen sie auch in einem schönen, symbolischen Datum, 11. September, hatte so viel ausgelöst. Aber dieses Gefühl, es geht hier um eine Sache. Es könnte verloren gehen.
Ist nicht komplett von der Hand zu weisen, muss ich sagen. Und da muss man auch sagen, funktioniert die PR der Gegenseite oder die PsiOps schon deutlich besser. Durch den Entzug eines einfach polizierbaren Feindbildes ist es natürlich auch weniger leicht, Leute mit einfachen und klaren Argumenten zu motivieren, warum sie zu einer solchen Demo kommen sollen. Die Themen sind ja nicht vom Tisch. Sie sind bloß nicht mehr subplakativ darstellbar wie damals. Also das ist, glaube ich, das, was da passiert ist.
Könnte man vielleicht mal dann doch dazu übertreten, dass man so einen positiven Gegenentwurf der ganzen Sache startet? Oder wäre das zu viel für eine Demo?
Na ja, eine Demo ist eher eine Aktionsform, wo man sich jetzt nicht zusammensetzt und sagt, überlegen wir mal, was wir da tun können. Sondern das ist was Repräsentatives. Da gehen die Leute auf die Straße, die gegen oder für ein bestimmtes Konzept sind.
Aber das meine ich ja genau.
Dadurch, dass es so viele verschiedene Gruppen sind, die aber gemeinsam zumindest erkannt haben, dass es da eine Alternative braucht. Also ich glaube, das sind alles Probleme, die inhaltlich anders angegangen werden müssen.
Also das mit dem Dafür-Sein ist ja ganz einfach. Die Demo heißt ja schon Freiheit statt Angst. Die ist halt irgendwie für Freiheit und gegen Angst.
Das ist so der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner.
Okay, darauf können wir uns einigen. Ich hab jetzt auf der Liste noch eine Sache, die wir hier noch nicht erwähnt haben, also sagen die viel mal kurz zwischendurch, aber haben wir noch nicht gesagt. Und das war Swift.
Swift, oh Swift ist ein ganz pikantes Thema. Auch wieder, weil die FDP sich an ihre Wahlversprechen nur sehr zaghaft erinnern konnte.
Okay, also reinfolge, was ist Swift? Das hat die FDP versprochen und wie ist der Stand?
Swift. Swift ist erstmal ein internationales Verfahren zum Geld durch die Gegend transportieren. Also sozusagen Überweisungen zwischen Banken finden per Swift statt, wenn es nicht noch regionale oder landesweite Netze gibt, aber wenn ich von hier ins Ausland überweise, dann läuft das in der Regel über Swift. Also erstmal so eine Art Bankengeldwechselstube, wo die ganzen Banken angeschlossen sind. Und die Amerikaner haben ein traditionelles Interesse an den europäischen Überweisungsdaten, und zwar auch wieder mit dem Argument der Terroraufklärung. Also es geht darum, zu gucken, wie finanzieren sich die Terroristen. Können wir die finden anhand der Geldbewegung. Was natürlich unausgesprochen auch immer ein bisschen dahinter steht, ist der Faktor Industrie-Spionage. Also wenn ich weiß, wie viel Firma A an Firma B überwiesen hat, nachdem ich weiß, dass sie ein bestimmtes Geschäft abgeschlossen haben, dann weiß ich wie der Preis war. Das steckt damit drin, da reden sie immer nicht drüber, offiziell geht es um Terroristen. Und die Amerikaner hatten lange Zeit Zugriff auf diese SWIFT-Daten, weil das Rechenzentrum dafür in den USA stand und die Leitungen eh an ihnen vorbeigelaufen sind. Und dann hat SWIFT irgendwann angefangen, das Rechenzentrum in die Schweiz zu verlagern und dann hatten sie plötzlich keine Daten mehr. Und dann sind die Amerikaner zur EU gelaufen, haben gesagt, irgendwie doch, gib uns doch mal die Daten. Und dann entbrannte sich tatsächlich, zur Abwechslung, mal ein Streit zwischen dem Parlament und der Kommission. Also Kommission hat natürlich gesagt, klar, könnt ihr die Daten haben hier, habt ihr. Und das Parlament hat gesagt, irgendwie, nee, wollen wir, sind wir dann doch nicht so. Und dann ging es hin und her. Und das Ende des Liedes ist, dass die Amerikaner die Daten jetzt tatsächlich offiziell bekommen. Also früher haben sie sich einfach genommen, jetzt bekommen sie von uns ausgehändigt.
Ich hatte gehofft, dass deine Argumentation noch ein bisschen länger ist, weil ich gerade einen Schluck Getränk im Mund hatte. Einmal Profis arbeiten hier. Also auch auf Gefahr hin, dass es jetzt 20 Minuten zu früh ist. Aber damit haben wir es oder gibt es noch irgendwas, was wir vergessen haben?
Ich hatte noch so ein paar Punkte, die ich erwähnen wollte. Also unter anderem irgendwie, weil es in den Nachrichten lief, das Arbeitnehmer-Datenschutz-Gesetz, was gerade frisch umstritten ist. Also was auch ein bisschen die Theorie widerlegt, dass die Öffentlichkeit sich nicht mehr nicht für Datenschutz interessieren würde. Datenschutz ist mittlerweile ein Thema, das ganz weit oben ist. Bei dem Arbeitnehmer-Datenschutz-Gesetz soll es darum gehen, dass bestimmte Sachen verboten werden sollen. So soll es zum Beispiel nicht mehr erlaubt sein, seiner Arbeitnehmer beim Pinkeln zu filmen. Wo man sich fragen muss, wie es war erlaubt.
Das wäre meine nächste Frage gewesen, in der Tat.
Da hab ich auch gewundert, dass gesagt wurde, ja Wanzen und so weiter sind auch ab sofort nicht erlaubt.
Also es werden einige Sachen verboten, wo man sich einen Kopf fasst und fragt, warum ging das überhaupt je? Und auf der anderen Seite sollen aber andere Sachen erlaubt werden, die bislang verboten sind. Also die Deutsche Bahn ist ja in ihrem Datenschutzskandal darüber gestolpert, dass sie eine Rasterfahndung gegen ihre Mitarbeiter über ihre eigenen Datenbanken gemacht hat. Und das soll in Zukunft erlaubt sein. Und im Ausgleich dafür, dass man nicht mehr beim Pinkeln gefilmt werden darf, soll man jetzt mit öffentlich sichtbaren Kameras beim Arbeiten gefilmt werden dürfen. Ja, das verkaufen sie uns tatsächlich als Datenschutzverbesserung, dass man jetzt beim Arbeiten gefilmt werden darf.
Also ich finde, bei mir ist das okay, weil bei mir ist die Kamera eine Webcam, kann man auf fritz.de gucken, was der Markus so an seinem Pult macht, das finde ich auch in Ordnung. Aber so generell, wie sind Sie denn auf diese großartige Idee gekommen? Und warum demonstriert da keiner gegen?
Ich glaube, da sind tatsächlich einige Leute dagegen, also die Gewerkschaften finden das alles nicht besonders toll. Und die Arbeitgeberverbände finden das auch nicht toll, aber aus den gegenteiligen Gründen. Es ist auf jeden Fall etwas, was, also wenn das Gesetz nicht bis dann noch beschlossen wird, auf der Demo Thema werden kann. Und dann hatte ich noch eine weitere Gesprächsthemenkarte, und zwar irgendwie Demo-Radgeber. Demo-Radgeber.
Also wie man, wenn man sagt, wir gehen jetzt davon aus, ihr geht dahin, wie man sich dort verhält.
Genau, weil da gibt es irgendwie so Spielregeln zu beachten, und es gibt diverse Demo-Radgeber, die empfehlenswert sind. Der CCC hat auch Demo-Grundregeln für Nerds rausgegeben, wo also das grundsätzliche Verhalten mal in eine nerdsugängliche Sprache übersetzt wurde. Ich kann ja mal ein bisschen auslesen. Jede Demonstration bekommt verschiedene Auflagen. Das sind die erweiterten ACL, wo auch die Route konfiguriert ist. Meistens ist die Route nicht nach Effizienz- oder Geschwindigkeitskriterien optimiert, soll im Gegenteil die Öffentlichkeitsexposures jedes Paketes maximieren. Auch erwähnenswert ist natürlich der Demo-Ratgeber der Roten Hilfe. Was tun, wenn es brennt? Sollte man mal reingucken, steht viel dazu drin, was denn die Rechte des Einzelnen sind, wenn man doch in Konflikt mit dem Team Grün gerät. Wobei ich ja immer noch der Hoffnung bin, dass wir es dieses Jahr mal hinbekommen, dass sowohl Team Schwarz als auch Team Grün sich an die Spielregeln halten.
Auf Twitter meinte gerade jemand, die Polizeigewerkschaft selber hätte ja auch dazu aufgerufen, an der Demo teilzunehmen.
Das finde ich gut, das muss ich mal sagen. Staatsbürger in Uniform sind Staatsbürger und haben dieselben Rechte und dieselben Interessen. Im Grunde genommen sind die meisten Leute, die in Uniform zu dieser Demo kommen, auf unserer Seite. Das Problem sind, wie immer, dass auch die eine Minderheit radikaler Spinner hat, die gerne mal die Langhaare geklatschen geht. Und genauso gibt es halt irgendwie Leute, die gerne mal irgendwie randale Demo, Steine werfen, habe ich Bock drauf, die sollen bitte auch zu Hause bleiben. Für uns ist jeder willkommen, der in dem Thema der Veranstaltung sich wiederfindet und der bereit ist, diese Aktionsform als solche zu akzeptieren, ob er eine schwarze oder eine grüne Uniform anhat.
Noch was? Oder war es das dann wirklich?
Ich glaube jetzt so ist es wirklich.
Hey, da haben wir noch genug Platz für Mike, der nämlich auf Twitter gelesen hat, dass es da einen Spendenaufruf gibt und jetzt nicht genau weiß, was er damit anfangen soll. Hallo Mike.
Hallo.
Ja, sag mal, was ist deine Frage zum Spendenaufruf auf Twitter?
Ja, ich wollte einfach mal wissen, warum kosten Demos diese Art für die Veranstalter so furchtbar viel Geld? Also, da soll irgendwie 2000 Euro über den Ladentisch gehen für diesen Einspendenaufruf. Und die Veranstalter reiten sich die Hände danach. Jetzt war meine Frage, warum?
Also Kosten hat so eine Demo auf jeden Fall eine Menge. Du musst alles mieten, was du hast an Bühne, was du brauchst zum Absperren. Du musst die Straßenreinigung hinterher bezahlen. Also da kommt schon alles zusammen Flyerdruck. Du musst vielleicht Leute durch die Gegend bewegen. Du hast Material. Du musst die Leute, die da irgendwie 10 oder 12 Stunden Helfer machen, vielleicht mit Essen versorgen. Also das läppert sich. Es ist nicht besonders viel Geld für eine Veranstaltung dieser Größe, aber so eine Veranstaltung kostet einfach Geld.
Stell dich das zufrieden, Mike, oder?
Ja, ich meine, viel mehr gibt es ja wohl nichts zu sagen, oder? Ich meine, wenn man schon mal so was veranstaltet hat, dann weiß man ja, wo die Posten hingehen. Im Prinzip hat man hier wohl nichts anderes als denselben Stress wie bei jeder anderen öffentlichen Veranstaltung auch, ne?
Genau so ist das. Also ich hoffe, dass die Leute mit den Finanzen zu tun haben, dann auch die entsprechenden Abrechnungen im Sinne der Transparenz, die wir ja auch immer fordern, so Transparenz und Datenschutz, was für ein wunderbares Gegensatzpaar. Aber ich glaube, im Fall von Mittelverwendung bei solchen Demonstrationen ist es angebracht, schon hinterher danach zu fragen, ob die auch ordentlich ausgegeben wurden. Wobei ich mir da auch relativ sicher sind, dass sie das werden. Also das machen schon Leute, denen man da vertrauen kann.
Mir wurde hier im Chat zur Sendung noch zugetragen, da meinte jemand, der Demo würden wohl noch 10.000 Euro fehlen. Und die Adresse, wo man sich das alles anlesen kann, wenn man ganz ganz ganz genau wissen will, ist freiheitstattangst.de. Ist ja ganz einfach zu merken, genauso wie die Demo heißt. freiheitstattangst.de. Mike, bist du zufriedengestellt? Würdest du auch zur Demo gehen?
Das weiß ich noch nicht. Da sind familiäre Hindernisse beziehungsweise Feiertage dazwischen.
Na wie, da geht ja einfach alle zusammen.
Mal schauen, wie das wird, ja.
Oder wenn du nicht kommst, schickst du jemanden als würdige Vertretung?
Ich werd auf jeden Fall mal rumfragen. Also ganz ungeschon, kommt so die Nördrige hier aus der Ecke nicht davon.
Na dann, viel Spaß.
Ja, euch auch noch.
Tschüss. So, dann haben wir noch eine sehr schicke Frage von Sarah zur Volkszählung. Sarah, hallo. Hallo. Was ist deine Frage zur Volkszählung?
Und zwar hat mein Cousin auch diesen Fragebogen bekommen. Und er möchte den eigentlich nicht ausfüllen. Jetzt stand in dem Brief allerdings, dass er sonst eine Strafe von 200 Euro bekommt. Und er möchte es nicht ausfüllen. Er ist auch noch in der Ausbildung und könnte dann die 200 Euro auch nicht zahlen.
Warum will er es nicht ausfüllen?
Weil er einfach keine Lust drauf hat. Weil es einfach zu viele Fragen sind. Fragen, die er auch nicht beantworten möchte.
Hast du da mal ein paar Beispiele? Weil ich habe so einen Fragebogen noch nie gesehen.
Ich kann ihn jetzt schnell holen. Ich habe ihn hier.
Ja, mach mal.
Das ist so ein richtig fettes Ding. Das ist echt übel. Und dann stand in dem Brief auch noch, wird einem richtig angedroht, wenn du das jetzt nicht auswillst, dann musst du 200 Euro bezahlen, als wenn man jetzt Staatsamt Nummer 1 wäre, weil man das jetzt nicht auswillst.
Hier Frage an die beiden anwesenden CCC-Leute. Da führt dann auch tatsächlich kein Weg vorbei. Entweder ausfüllen oder man zahlt es.
Ja.
Ich würde sagen, so sieht das aus. Es gibt natürlich immer noch den dritten Weg, sich einen guten Anwalt zu suchen und das mal von einem Gericht aus zu diskutieren. Aber der ist auf jeden Fall mit Kosten jenseits von 200 Euro verbunden.
Ich würde aber beinahe auch behaupten, dass es de facto noch die Möglichkeit gibt, dass eben hinreichend viele Leute diesen Fragebogen nicht ausfüllen, dass das für jenseits der nicht tragbar wird, da entsprechend gegen so viele Leute vorzugehen. Also da wäre eventuell schon interessant, sich da mal vielleicht zu organisieren.
Meine Oma hat jetzt angefangen, den auszufüllen und hat dann bei einigen Fragen wirklich, also hat die, keine Ahnung, erst in zwei Seiten dann irgendwelche Sachen angekreuzt und dann bei den einigen Fragen hingeschrieben, die dadurch, dass er eben noch in der Ausbildung ist und jetzt erst anfängt, nicht eindeutig beantworten kann, hingeschrieben so, ja, dass es schwerfällt, die Fragen zu beantworten.
Und hast du den Fragebogen jetzt zur Hand?
Ja.
Dann schlag doch mal, also erzähl doch mal, was da so drin steht.
Also man muss sämtliche Sachen bei seinen Wohnverhältnissen angeben. Also Miete und Größe werden noch bei einem wohnen, über Arbeitsplatz, was man da verdient, bis hin zu irgendwelchen, keine Ahnung, ob man verheiratet ist oder ledig, oder ob man Kinder hat, zur Arbeitssuche und Arbeitsplatzwechsel, ob man das in den nächsten Monaten vorhat oder ob man jetzt irgendwie umziehen möchte oder auswandern möchte oder sowas.
Okay, da steht also alles drin, das ist ja wirklich das komplette Programm. Gero hat auch gerade angerufen, will dazu was sagen. Hallo Gero.
Hi, ja ich wollte nur kurz nachhaken, dass dieser Fragewogen, der da ist, jetzt nicht die Volkszählung selbst ist, sondern der sogenannte Mikrozensus, den es schon ziemlich lange gibt und mit der Volkszählung, die jetzt nächstes Jahr ansteht, ja eher bedingt was zu tun hat.
Das hatte ich jetzt aber hier anders verstanden. Das war es doch so, dass beides zusammengehört oder nicht?
Ja schon, aber der Mikrozensus als solches, also den gibt es halt immer, also das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie explizit zu dieser Volkszählung, sondern jedes Jahr gibt es einfach so eine Fragewogen.
Und du findest das okay?
Nein, finde ich nicht. Weil ich auch finde, dass das eigentlich nirgends zusammengehalten werden sollte. Also weil ich da finde auch, dass einfach viele Sachen sind, die eigentlich niemandem was angehen, außer allenfalls mich selbst. Also mich definitiv, aber alle anderen.
Hast du so ein Ding auch schon mal bekommen?
Nee, habe ich glücklicherweise noch nicht.
Woher weißt du das so genau, woher kennst du dich damit aus?
Ich bin auch zum einen in der Demo-Orga aktiv und habe mich auch der Volksfehlung ein bisschen beschäftigt.
Wenn du bei der Demo-Orga aktiv bist, da hat gerade jemand angerufen und wollte mal ganz genau wissen, wofür braucht er denn eigentlich so viel Kohle?
Genau, da habe ich auch schon überlegt, ob ich dann auch anrufe. Wurde eigentlich schon ganz gut erklärt. Es ist gerade sowas wie die Bühne, wobei da haben wir diesmal glaube ich ziemlich Glück, die werden wir relativ günstig kriegen, aber eben sowas wie die Flyer, die Plakate, die wir irgendwie gedruckt haben, die richtig Geld kosten. Eben die Versorgung, die Toiletten, die irgendwie hinter der Bühne noch stehen müssen, da halt insgesamt für die Leute, die irgendwie da sind, für Absperrvorrichtungen, für alles, was so irgendwie zusammenkommt.
Kostet denn diese Demo auch sozusagen Gebühren im Sinne von Anmeldungen oder Polizeieinsatz oder sowas?
Muss ich jetzt gerade passen.
Meines Wissens zahlt das der Staat. Also die Anwesenheit von Team Grün ist steuerfinanziert.
Genau, ich meine, dafür müssten wir nichts zahlen. Werden wir jedenfalls jetzt neu.
Und die andere Frage, die hier aufgekommen ist, ist, ob man das irgendwo nach der Demo nachgucken kann, was wofür ausgegeben ist und wie die Spenden verwendet wurden.
Also intern machen wir das schon. Ob das irgendwie öffentlich wird, weiß ich nicht, weil viele der Bündnispartner einen expliziten Teil bezahlt haben. Also da hat jetzt Organisation X irgendwie unsere Flyer bezahlt und Organisation Y eben irgendwie einen Teil für die Bühne bezahlt oder wie auch immer. Dass das im Nachhinein öffentlich gemacht wird, wer quasi was bezahlt hat, das glaube ich nicht. Also wie viel es insgesamt gekostet hat, das kann sein.
Aber zumindest wofür die Spenden verwendet worden sind.
Dass man das im Nachhinein irgendwie nachgucken kann.
Na das wäre schon schick. Gero, vielen Dank erstmal. Sehr gut, gleich noch Hausaufgaben bekommen. Sarah. Sarah? Bist du noch da? Du bist noch da. Das heißt also die einzige Chance, die tatsächlich besteht, um nochmal kurz zurückzukommen, ist Organisation. Also sagen, mit mehreren Leuten zusammen tun und dann versuchen richtig dick Alarm zu machen.
Wie viele Seiten sind das denn?
Ähm, viele. Also es sind irgendwie 53 Seiten oder so und hinten dran ist aber nochmal so eine Belehrung. Was passiert, wenn man das jetzt nicht ausfüllt und auf welcher Rechtsgrundlage das alles passiert? Aber einige Fragen sind auch freiwillig und dann sind wieder so Fragen, die man überspringen kann.
Steht da auch was passiert, wenn man das nicht wahrheitsgemäß ausfüllt?
Das hab ich jetzt, ich hab's nur ehrlich gesagt nur über Aflogen und ich hab nur gesehen, da war noch ein Schreibenbeiderstand wirklich einfach nur drinnen, wenn man das nicht ausfüllt und zurückschickt, kriegt man einfach eine Strafe von 200 Euro.
Ich denke, das wäre ein Punkt, wo man nochmal nachgucken kann, weil irgendwie das, wenn, also es kann ja vielleicht sein, dass da irgendwo steht, ja sie sind verpflichtet, das wahrheitsgemäß auszufüllen, wenn aber die damit keine Strafandrohungen verbunden ist, dann zwingt einen ja keiner, das wahrheitsgemäß auszufüllen. Also da kann man auch irgendwie, wie früher bei den Rollen spielen, da nimmt man sich halt einen Würfel und würfelt sich seinen Census-Charakter zusammen.
Ja, mal abgesehen davon wissen die ja gar nicht, ob es stimmt, also sie wollen jetzt überprüfen.
Ich denke, das ist nämlich das, wo das mit dem Census und dem Registerabgleich reinkommt, weil dann gucken sie nach, ob das wahrheitsgemäß ausgefüllt ist. Das ist noch der Mikro-Census, also noch sozusagen ein Fünfundzeichen alte. Wahrscheinlich kannst du die mal prüfen, guck lieber nochmal genau nach, aber das wäre sozusagen mein Tipp, mal zu gucken, was einem passiert, wenn man da einfach irgendwas ankreuzt und dann halt irgendwas anzukreuzen. Symmetrische Muster machen sich auch immer gut.
Mich würde echt mal interessieren, was in diesem Ding drin steht. Also kann man das sich irgendwie mal online stellen oder sowas?
Ich könnte mir jetzt die Mühe machen und 51 Seiten einscannen und online stellen, wenn du das möchtest.
Ist das verboten? Also ich will jetzt gerade sagen, ich will jetzt niemand irgendwie... Gibt es dann wieder diese Urheberrechts-Dinge, wo man dann Leuten ein Schnippchen schlagen kann oder sowas? Oder könnte man das machen?
Ist der schon zu Teil ausgefüllt, also sind da schon Fehler voreingefüllt oder ist das komplett blank zum Ausfüllen?
Das ist komplett blank zum Ausfüllen, zum Ankreuzen.
Und ihr habt auch noch nichts eingetragen?
Doch, meine Oma hat ein paar Sachen angekreupt.
Okay, dann lassen wir das mit dem online stellen auf jeden Fall.
Ja, aber das ist nicht viel, das sind nur so unwichtige Sachen, die sind sie männlich, weiblich und dann haben sie Geburtstag.
Das muss dann echt nicht sein.
Das kann man dann verdecken.
Stichprobe, da, hier. Okay, es gibt diesen Mikro-Census-Fragebogen online im Bus nicht.
Ach gut, super. Hätten wir das wenigstens erklärt. Sarah, auf jeden Fall vielen Dank für den Anruf und ich hoffe, ihr tut euch das zusammen und passiert irgendwas.
Dann kann ich natürlich auch gleich mal nach den Rechtsgrundlagen gucken.
Was wäre eigentlich auch mein...
Okay, Leute...
.eine eigene Sendung.
Ja, das machen wir vielleicht ein andermal. Jetzt ist nämlich folgendes. Ich werde jetzt mal kurz den Tim rannehmen. Hallo, Tim. Tim, wo bist du?
Hallo? Hallo, hier.
Ah, so. Es ist jetzt drei vor zwölf. Du hast eine Frage zu Elena. Die Frage ist, warum hast du nicht von der Stunde angerufen?
Weil ich da noch so doof war und mit einem Freund telefoniert habe und leider nicht den Chaos Computer Club gehört habe, den ich mir morgen aber ganz definitiv als Podcast runterladen werde.
Sehr gut. Da hat der Tim das ganz richtig gemacht. Das könnt ihr nämlich auch machen. Auf Chaosradio.de oder Fritzee gibt es nämlich einen Podcast zu dieser Sendung. Aber die Frage zu Elena können wir nicht beantworten, weil jetzt warten schon wieder ein bisschen Smart, die ihre Sendung umbenannt haben. Die heißt jetzt nicht mehr Night Flight, die heißt jetzt Musikmaschine. Oder Musikmaschine Night Flight oder irgendwas zusammen. Auf jeden Fall wollen sie es euch von der bedreckig bis stilvoll und elegant geben. Also der bedreckig kann ich mir bei Smart echt gut vorstellen, aber stilvoll und elegant, ich weiß nicht, wie die das hinkriegen wollen. Aber das könnt ihr dann gleich mal gucken. So, wir haben heute über die Freiheit statt Angst Demo gesprochen mit Nibler und Andreas vom Chaos Computer Club. Es gab viele Gründe, warum man da hingehen sollte. Werdet ihr da hingehen?
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Na klar.
Wie werdet ihr aussehen?
Ich glaube, ich werde Fahrrad fahren.
Ich werde mein Longboard mitnehmen.
Und so klamottenmäßig?
Ja, auch.
Mit Klamotten? Mit Klamotten. Also mit Kamera und Klamotten. Könntet ihr beide wahrscheinlich auch auf der Demo sehen. Den Podcast und alle Infos gibt es wie gesagt auf chaosradio.de und diese Sendung könnt ihr also dann genau wieder in einem Monat hören. Wenn jetzt noch ein Song, der ausnahmsweise keine Creative Commons Musik ist, den Herr Nibler hier angeschleppt hat, kannst du kurz erklären, was das ist und warum wir es jetzt hören.
Es ist für Raute Chaos Radio.
Na dann, viel Spaß und gute Nacht euch noch.